and we are live what's up belief nation
happy Thursday it's time for another AMA
ask me your questions entrepreneur
questions I'm trying to make a
commitment to be here every Thursday for
you guys
whether it's me solo like this doing an
MA or I have a guest on board I'm
excited I'm excited to to do this it's
been a while and so there's the live
chat on the side leave your questions
there and let's plow through them and
have a good time together because
Thursday is important this is the most
important day of your life let's do it
first up Chris Chris always is the early
bird Chris always has those questions
coming in early any tips on how to
manage a side business as a reseller
online what is a good royalty percentage
high how high or low should you not go
Chris it just depends on so this is
really important it depends on your
margins it's what's called margin to
motivate so if you are reselling
something I don't know what side you on
whether you have somebody who is
reselling your stuff or you are being a
reseller for somebody else but either
way you think of margin to motivate how
much do I need to make from this thing
that's gonna motivate me to go off and
sell it and it depends on what the
margin is for that product so there's no
fixed number as an example if I am
selling software in my first business
software company we get between 30 and
40 percent Commission because it's
software because there's no cost that is
variable that's ongoing it's all fixed
costs at the start so I can afford to
make 60% or 70% on the deal and still
come out making a lot of money and when
that competitor sorry when that
distributor or seller is selling our
stuff at 30 to 40% compared to when he's
making 10 to 20 percent on somebody
else's product they have them the margin
to motivate them to go up and sell my
thing if I'm a real estate agent you
know if you're making two to
two-and-a-half percent commission off of
a property it's a different story
because the margins are different right
I'm also selling much more expensive
product so you just need to it's hard to
say like what a good percentage is it
depends on the business if I am
reselling it if I am the reseller
Chris if you're the one trying to make
money on the side doing this absolutely
number one most important thing is only
work with products and services that you
would recommend to your mom things that
you actually use yourself things that
are helpful in your life and your
business that you can confidently
recommend to the people in your life and
say you need to go and buy this not that
you're gonna be in people's faces but
you have to have absolute love and
passion for the thing that you are
selling and know that it's going to work
because a lot of times these situations
the person who is most confident wins so
if you are absolutely confident in the
product or service that you are
providing you will win in the face to
face conversation or by email or making
videos like this
your confidence that your energy speaks
for you before you even say a word right
and so you have to have that level of
confidence and the only way that happens
if you actually believe in the thing
that you're doing where most people are
just looking for ways to make money on
the side they'll take any product any
promotion try to sell it and it doesn't
work out well guess why because you've
never used the thing in your life and so
start with what are the products or
services that I'm actually using then go
down to do they have an affiliate
program do they have a way for me to
make money selling their thing or not
and then build a list around around the
community that you think would be
valuable so for me it's entrepreneurs
right and if I recommend products tools
software websites YouTube videos
whatever it is I have a community of
entrepreneurs who want to believe in
themselves you wanna do something
powerful important right and so when I
recommend something it's only because
I've I've used that right and so start
building your list start building your
community whether it's through email or
YouTube or Instagram or whatever the
community connection is you start
building that up and it's based around
you and as you're using something and
find any value in it making money from
it then you can start selling
commissions and creating more products
like I made my books I love the books I
think these are two amazing books right
I read this book every single morning
this book had a huge impact on my life
and then the research that went behind
it and uncomfortable talking to people
about it I think everybody needs to read
these two books and that's not because
they're mine is because I believe it
because I think if you read it it's
gonna make a big change in your
life right that's why I do what I do and
so you need to have that level of
emotional commitment to the products and
services that you are selling so start
there and not just looking for an
arbitrary 10% 20% 30% Commission
thank you for the kresson crest thank
you for the question Chris got that out
next up Mike Paulus $5 super chat he
says have some espresso on me have a
great day thank you Mike listen I just
came back actually from going to Tim
Hortons it's my favorite coffee here in
Canada and I bought an extra-large to
milk one sugar for me and I bought an
extra-large hot chocolate for my
security guard the lawn downstairs
shadow toodle on
so that cost just about five bucks just
on there like 475 for some things though
that's on you
thank you Mike I appreciate you know
what Mike Mike if you're watching this I
want to I want to repay the gratitude
with more gratitude I'm gonna send you a
signed copy of one of my books because
you sent me that super chat because you
are showing gratitude before I even came
on I appreciate it man
email email me or you know it even
better at the comment of this video
after it goes live put it down put your
put your information down in comments
once the video is done and we'll figure
out a way to get you a signed copy of my
book that's what happens when you show
up and give love guys good job Mike
okay questions coming in if you tagged
me it's gonna be a lot easier for me to
see it while they are flying in thank
you for the love guys let's go
what do we got Jay should you follow
your passion and go for opportunities so
here's the thing is both right you
follow your passion and in doing that
you look for opportunities and so if I
look at most people do the other way
around by the way most people just look
for opportunities go back to my first
question today right and then they end
up not making any money because they're
chasing little tiny pennies and dollars
instead of being able to do something
really impactful meaningful looking at
me I I wanted to help entrepreneurs I
went to a my one of my first speaking
gigs my first one in North America and
through people showed up free event I'm
like how am I ever going to make money
if only three people come to a free
event but I had to keep doing it because
it was my passion I love helping
entrepreneurs it's hard to make money
helping entrepreneurs sometimes because
a lot of entrepreneurs don't have money
right it's like well how am I ever gonna
make money off this if I'm if you're
selling to people who don't have money I
knew I had to keep going because it
filled my soul because it's something
that I'm deeply passionate about and
then while you're doing the thing that
you love you're looking for
opportunities to be able to make money
doing it right and so for me it started
with the website that became the YouTube
channel it became books it became brand
deals and became speaking gigs all of
the ways that I'm making money right now
with my business I never anticipated I
never had aspirations of being a
youtuber when I first started my channel
I never wanted to write books I said I
don't want to write books because I
don't need books to open up a door a lot
of times people wrote a book just to
have it on their resume zero interest in
just having a book on my resume and be
able to use it to get speaking gigs hide
zero interest I never thought I would
get speaking gigs because who hire
speakers corporations why would a
corporation want to hire me to come in
and speak to them I'm going to tell
everybody to go be an entrepreneur right
what company's gonna want to hire me to
come in and speak to them and so every
every opportunity that I have now I
never anticipated when I was going into
it but it came and I started looking for
them right I'm helping entrepreneurs I
know I'm not gonna sell I know somebody
in that group those three people who
came to a free event they're not gonna
pay me a thousand dollars to be there
and so how do I make this into a
business well I'm gonna keep following
my passion keep pursuing the thing that
I love doing and while I'm doing that
look for opportunities this is big
decisions with the heart small ones with
the head so the heart is I love helping
entrepreneurs I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
I'm gonna live it and breathe it I love
what this is what I'm gonna be doing
with my life and then my head is okay I
need to figure out how I'm gonna make
money doing this right I mean I sold my
business I didn't have to do anything if
I didn't want to for a while but I still
need to find a way to make money one for
myself but two if you want to do
something big you need to make money to
build a team because you can only do so
much yourself and so heart big decisions
head small decisions you are following
your passion that's the big decision
with the heart and then your
is helping you figure out how to
actually make it into something that
generates money for you good
next Dominick guys tagged me tease for
me to see Dominick K Evan I'm I'm on a
full-time job trying to get out of it by
doing photography but I cannot get
myself to contact companies and offer my
services you just got to start doing man
you got to start doing what I would do
is I would do two things I would I would
one look at what are the things that get
me feeling unstoppable and bold and and
confident and feeling like I can do
anything whatever that thing is and then
do that before you have to start
contacting companies right so if it's
watching a video over it's reading a
book whatever the thing is it gets you
feeling really unstoppable and feeling
bold you know for me I woke up I read a
page from my book
and then I made a video that I posted to
my Instagram into my Twitter and that's
how I start every day and that all in
takes I don't know five to ten minutes
but after I read the page and then I
make my video I'm like I'm on fire right
I go from being tired and it was a rough
night last night Nina didn't sleep very
well and so when she sleeps poorly I
sleep poorly
and so I'm waking up and I'm I'm tired
it's been kind of a crazy week with with
some of the people in my life and so I
mean that happens and so I woke up not
feeling super energized I did my thing
read the page made the video and boom
now I'm ready to go and that's gonna
translate to you guys it's gonna
translate to every other interview I do
later on today and all the work that I'm
I'm pouring out so find the thing that
that gets you feeling that bold
unstoppable confidence and then put that
into your your morning routine just
before you go off and have to make those
calls the second thing would be just
play it out like play out the regret I
love using regret as a filter to allow
me to go harder today and so you want
this this is your dream right you say
this is your dream you want to be a
photographer this is what you want to do
with your life you want to create
lasting moments and memories for people
you want your grandkids to look at this
and be proud of what you're doing
and so if you don't take action then
what's gonna happen and in the micro
it's not a big deal like okay not today
tomorrow but and then tomorrow and then
tomorrow right you keep putting things
off it doesn't seem like a big deal to
not doing something important today but
if you keep letting that happen fast
forward 30 years 40 years 50 years
you're still at this crappy job or maybe
if you've retired from that crappy job
you don't know what to do with your life
you regret not having done your
photography business you see people with
less talent in you taking off and making
a lot of money and you become this
really resentful angry unhappy person
all because you decided that you were
too scared to go off and make these
contacts into companies and so that's
what I that's what I put on myself right
that's the pressure that I put on myself
that 40 years of regret bring it back to
right now if I don't do something today
then that's the life I'm gonna have and
that pain
forces me through the immediate pain
that I'm facing right now which might be
the fear of contacting companies
whatever the thing is that you have to
do today so those two things I highly
encourage you do it I highly encourage
you put into your regular routine it
makes a world of difference and it's so
so so important because as entrepreneurs
we don't have a boss you don't have
somebody breathing down your neck and
saying hey you got to get this done if
you show up late for work
nobody's gonna be calling you out right
if you have a job and you don't show up
for work are you sure you know an hour
late you're gonna have somebody who's
gonna reprimand you and so it's funny
how much more work people put in for a
job that they hate and they're willing
to work for themselves just because they
don't have any kind of accountability so
you need the four set accountability on
yourself huge huge huge huge impact so
important for entrepreneurs next tarun
how do you learn from your mentors and
not just business and entrepreneurship
but also about relationships you just
make it a priority whatever you want to
learn somebody has figured it out
whatever the thing is that you want to
do whether that's be a great
entrepreneur be great in the gym build
massive muscles have a fantastic
relationship there's been so many people
who figured it out and talked about it
so if you want to learn about
entrepreneurship my channel is a great
place to go it's where I learn right I
learned from all these
videos and I'm putting up I learned from
the book that I wrote and collected
information from we had a series on our
channel a while ago called believe love
which never really got legs which is
based around relationships there's I
don't know five videos or so if you if
you search believe love you can find it
that's maybe a good starting point but
anybody who's who is the expert on
relationships they have content they
have videos they have books they have a
podcast they have seminars here you can
go to write they have all of these
things that you can you can learn from
and so just make it an intention if you
woke up every day and set your intention
to learn about how to build a great
relationship and you started consuming
the content that allowed you to do it
guess what you would just what so do it
next Hugo super Chuck you go thank you
for the super chat and go buy a coffee
can you recommend resources to learn
crowdfunding so you know I have not done
crowdfunding myself for all of these
things though it's not that difficult
it's just the time to put in to
understand it I'm looking at Instagram
as an example Instagram I took seriously
I started taking seriously a couple
weeks ago so if anybody is not follow me
on Instagram follow me on instagram at
Evan Carmichael pumping out content
daily and I knew nothing about Instagram
I had an account for I don't know if
five years six years something like that
and and we were putting out content but
I didn't care I didn't pay any attention
to it you know set a little bit of a
strategy we were pumping out content
every day but there wasn't really a
focus on Instagram I made a decision a
couple weeks ago that I want to focus on
Instagram I want to get better at this I
want to learn how this thing works and
so I go to YouTube and I go to Google
and I start typing how to win on
Instagram right Instagram algorithm and
I start learning and I start testing and
I start seeing what works I post a
picture and see hmm okay there's
reaction to that okay if I take off the
branding how does it do if I put a quote
versus me versus a video versus a
collage like how does it all work and I
start seeing what what ends up doing
well and I did that really quickly right
on top of everything else that I'm doing
top of running multiple businesses and
meant
people and having a team that I need to
manage ain't doing three YouTube videos
a day and everything else right like you
find the time this is our priority
and it got to the point where this is
like a week in a week into my Instagram
strategy I'm meeting with a guy who's an
Instagram expert Instagram marketing
consultant and his knowledge base is not
that far away from what I know at least
in theory right everything he's talking
about I'm understanding this like maybe
one or two new concepts or he knows a
little bit more the execution because
he's done it a couple more times than I
have but it's almost a level playing
field after one week of me just
researching and so it's the same thing
with YouTube when I wanted to learn
YouTube I started digesting all of the
videos and all the content on how to be
great on YouTube and I subscribed to
Derral Eve's and I subscribe to Tim
Schmoyer and I was googling and I was
testing and I was trying so if I if I
wanted to get in the crowdfunding I'd be
doing all the same things I would be
looking at everybody's made videos on
crowdfunding everybody's written
articles on crowdfunding books probably
not so much because it's usually
outdated by the time you get the content
now I'd be looking at new videos like
2018 videos on crowdfunding I would be
looking at all the different
crowdfunding campaigns that maybe I've
supported in the past have I supported a
crowdfunding campaign before and what
made me do it
I'd be looking at all of the top
Kickstarter campaigns right now and
looking at their process so like
everybody has a video you got to make a
great video what makes a great video how
long is the video what's the story
behind the video what are the different
campaign levels like you can figure all
this stuff out really quickly just by
dissecting what other people are doing
and looking at the best practices and
that allows you to win you can get you
can pick up on what other people are
doing really really really quickly
the challenging part then becomes okay
now you need to innovate like what I'm
doing on YouTube right now there's two
to three people in in the YouTube world
that I'd like listening to for advice
and we'll have our powwows offline
chatting about what we're doing but I
already know the best practices and now
I'm creating new best practices so I'm
on the edge now because I'm the expert
in what I'm doing and so you might get
to that point to say okay what can I do
differently and some things will work
and
things won't but in terms of
recommending specific resources just
start researching you can you could be
the expert on crowdfunding within a week
you could just consume everything take
out the stuff that is not working right
that doesn't make sense
compare it to the campaign's that are
currently working on Kickstarter on the
other platforms and then do it and then
start it B be the guy actually in the
trenches doing the work and not just
sitting up in the theory next aneasha
another super chad you guys thank you
for the thank you for the super chat
love i have a web design business for
money now i go to school for psychology
i work but i want to be a speaker what
should i do what do i pick the focus on
so first off I would recommend following
the unlocking release series that we
have on this channel she had a full time
job she left I think she's in the chat
right now chatting away and she wanted
to be a speaker and very quickly had her
own TED talk we had corporate gigs with
sage and and other speaking
opportunities that she's done and now
she's transitioning towards coaching I
think for for all of this stuff you need
to go down parallel paths so if you have
a job you have a business you're doing
website design web business for money
great like you don't need to quit that
to go do your other thing but parallel
pass right and so if you want to be a
speaker you need to learn how to be a
great speaker right you need to practice
your speaking my like let's get into the
tactics what to do every day pick up
your phone three to five posts on your
stories on Instagram stories snapchat
stories you can share it to Facebook if
you want to to practice like to be a
great speaker you need to practice speak
and just like everything else and
chances are you're not that greatest
speaker yet right you need to be really
good at it
you need to practice right so every
single day every single day
three to five posts on your Instagram
stories on your snapchat stories and the
great thing is you don't need to be a
great editor write all the skills around
making higher quality YouTube content
you don't need to do that because
they're not expecting it just put on the
phone
I would start a YouTube channel and I
would make I would make a daily like
watch at Lily's doing every single day
she's doing a coach's corner on her
channel I would do a daily Q&A like this
what's the tech for this you don't need
a fancy microphone to do a daily Q&A
show you don't need to have a fantastic
webcam like if you have a laptop you
could do it you could do it from your
phone right you don't even need a laptop
and a webcam you could do live every day
from your phone practicing practicing
practicing you need to get better and
when you are great when you are creating
fantastic content when you have a
message right like a speaker has to have
a message what are you staying for
what's your message what I'm gonna learn
by following you right then you'll get
attention
like how do I get my speaking gigs
because people watch my youtube channel
every speaking again I've gotten in the
past number of years have all come
because people watch my youtube channel
so the more that you speak and the more
you put your content out there and this
goes for everything every business the
more you're putting it out there the
more people can see what you do and
think wow that person is awesome I want
to hire them and so it's either a
question of one like you're not doing it
enough so nobody sees your stuff or two
you're not good enough yet and and it's
the yet like it's fine if you're not
good at speaking yet then get practice
get better hustle hustle hustle hustle
when I first started as a speaker and I
went with my agent in New York you know
he told me I wasn't good enough to be a
speaker and and then I work with him
every single day and like three times a
day making different videos that he
would ask me to do I need give me
feedback can I make it better
it's just prioritizing the time where
other people the agency had a hard time
doing one video a week I did three a day
and that's how I got better and so it's
not that I have a amazing skill set if
you look back on my channel you'll see
that that I'm not that great you know my
early content I'm not a great speaker
that the points may be great but the
delivery really sucked and now almost
six six thousand videos I look at my
channel we're almost at six thousand
videos not all of them are public but
six thousand videos later I'm getting a
little bit better
or hey and I hopefully still continue to
get better and better and better and
better so if you're making money from
this job of this business great keep
doing that that's paying the bills and
now you need to work hard on becoming a
better speaker in creating great content
I want to go to your Instagram right
like if you had your Instagram account
you put it in the in the live chat right
now people would visit I might visit I
want to see your story if your story was
great if it moved me to want to do
something then guess what I'm gonna
subscribe to you right I'm gonna follow
you and every day I'm gonna look forward
to where's the Anisha story today if
it's just okay then I'm not gonna really
care that much and so the quantity leads
to the quality do it every single day
three to five times a day a daily show
on YouTube practice practice practice
practice practice get better while you
keep doing your business and people will
recognize you for your awesomeness as
you are as a speaker and when you get
really good people will pay attention
and they'll subscribe to you and then
they'll offer you speaking gigs go out
and get some get some job so good luck
follow the unlocking Lily's series think
you'll like that too and I'm excited to
see what you got to say
let's see you on your speaking career
next up J rise drop in 20 bucks in the
super chat I love you J rise that's
that's a triple triple Cheers quadruple
Cheers over the J rise props to the
one-week mastery talk rice or believe
what was my one week mastery talk I
don't remember what I said about one
week mastering but thank you J rise
appreciate it much love let's go being
awesome twenty donated twenty what is
that 20 pounds twenty something I don't
know what currency that is without a
question where's your question being
awesome or you you just are so awesome
that you don't have to have a question
thank you thank you guys for all the
love four-minute masters dropping some
some two pounds coffee on me much love I
appreciate it guys you guys are filling
my soul with the love okay let's go to
let's get some more questions
Oh J rise to one week master on the
crowdfunding yes you could learn
anything in one week if you wanted to
yes thank you for the reminder J rise I
gave a success five
thank you for the love man thank you for
all the positive responses to my post on
Instagram page a game of success I
appreciate the love I think it's really
really really important for all you guys
in terms of building your brand building
your business getting attention getting
awareness that that you respond and
people say I don't have the time they
respond how do you have time to respond
like guys I'm responding to almost every
comment whether it's people on my team
who helped me on the YouTube side or
like Instagram Twitter snapchat I'm
gonna spend time I spend time every
single day responding to people and it's
just finding the time it's just you look
at I would audit how you're spending
your day and say it's not about sleeping
in our less right it's about how are you
using the 16 hours that you are awake so
is on a photo shoot last week with the
celebrity photographer right in in
between the stats while he's setting up
his lenses and he's setting up the
lighting and setting up the gear and all
that stuff for like the next shot I'm on
I'm on my Instagram I'm responding to
people I'm on Twitter responding people
video replies 10 seconds at a time thank
you so much to the lover really
appreciate it you know means a lot to me
believe boom sent that means so much if
you want to build a following you want
people to care about you right if
somebody gives you a personal response
you're gonna feel amazing and so give
that to other people
right and if you're not getting enough
traction yet that people are writing
into you great then make content like if
you have five minutes while you're
standing in line make some content tell
me something tell me something I need to
hear make me feel something it's never
been easier to build a following it's
never been easier to get people to care
about what it is that you're doing but
you have to care about it first and then
pump that content out it'll make a huge
difference for all of your businesses
all you guys should be creating content
from the heart that people need to hear
that your message needs to be spread you
build your business next what do we got
David Evan what are your fundamentals of
the foundation of your life example
mental mentally emotionally spiritually
physically physically physically
physically
physically twice the fundamentals are
the foundation of my life I start with
believe it's my one word it's my most
important core value I need to wake up
and believe in the work that I'm doing
in the people that I'm around I just
think it's really important from there
everything else flows so I want an
environment that is belief right I want
a morning routine the book and the video
right now that that helps me believe my
my exercise routine and all that stuff I
guess isn't is you know it's more
maintenance stuff I mean I have a
personal trainer twice a week that comes
in we do weights yesterday we had a
crazy session you should do cardio twice
a week you know doesn't make an impact
I'm sure it does but it's not I wouldn't
put that there like the core foundation
I think honestly understanding who you
are understanding your most important
core value and then just living life
through that whatever that means to you
from the people you're with you know
Nina right helps me believe more myself
in the work that I'm doing from your
habits and your routines and the media
you consume and all of that stuff
everything flows from there and so it's
why my morning routine isn't as
important as what what's your morning
routine like what I do in the morning I
read a page from the book I make a video
and Instagram like maybe that means
nothing to you that's okay you know good
chunk of these people mean nothing to
you that's okay like you will not have
success by having a picture of my
parents and me at 8 years old on your
wall right but like but that may inspire
you to go off and do your thing like
what's when you walk into where you are
doing your work what's gonna help you
feel the thing that you want to feel so
this helps me feel believe what's your
one word and what helps you feel that on
a daily regular basis because if you
have to think about it
then it's really hard it's hard to wake
up every day and have to think about it
where the beauty of having in an
environment and the beauty of having
routines to set you up is it happens
it's automatic it happens if you do that
one thing then you're set up if you come
into an environment then you're set up
right and so to think your way through
it becomes a real challenge on an
everyday basis you can you can plow
through on a on a one day or two day or
even week or even couple weeks at a time
sometimes but that's where entrepreneurs
and fall off right we have great moments
and we fall back down and another great
day and then where we're falling back
down the problem is we're just not
consistent enough and so if you
understand what you want to be
consistent at which for me is believe
right it's the most important core value
for me I want that consistency every day
in my life so I need to design routines
a habits and environments around it
thank you for the love what do we got
Fahim
at the age of 13 I love I love the young
entrepreneurs I so wish I had this when
I was 13 oh I'd be using back to the
question of like how do i how do I be
great at relationships or be great at
crowdfunding Kickstarter that kind of
stuff like it's like it's this it's
being 13 years old if I was 13 and
wanted to learn YouTube I would be all
over these kinds of things asking
everybody questions giving them exactly
what I'm going through and getting
feedback on it I think it's so important
like you have the resources and the
tools and the opportunities right in
front of you you just have to take them
so what was this guy's question for him
let's go back up at the age of 13 how
can someone earn money without a proper
job how do they earn enough money to do
big things when it turns 16 like buy a
car so this is great this is what you'd
never learn in business class making
money is all about providing value the
more this is the most important rule
about money the more value you can
provide to somebody the more money
you're gonna make you want to make a lot
of money by the time you're 16 then you
have to ask yourself how can I provide a
lot of value to people by the time I'm
16 and so think about what you have as
skills that can contribute and help
people and it's never been easier or
better to be a young person because
historically young people would get a
lot of disrespect because you couldn't
provide value because you don't have
experience because you don't know what
you're doing but now with the insane
rise of technology people are actually
looking to young people and saying I
I need to learn I don't know what I'm
doing I need to learn from these young
people who know social media who know
technology who know where things are
going and so trying to use your youth as
a strength as opposed to a weakness when
I was how will those I'm in my first
business I was 18 19 19 19 19 my first
real business I had a bunch of you know
when I was 13 I was selling baseball
cards at garage sales and negotiating
over 5 cents 10 cents on different cards
I think all of that really helps just
build build your build your confidence
build your skill set even if you're not
doing anything on a big scale yet just
the idea of how do you how do you
negotiate with somebody how do you make
money how do you provide value super
important but when I was 19 I had my
first software company and I was too
afraid to call on big clients because I
thought I was too young they wouldn't
take me seriously and it wasn't until I
broke through that mindset that I
actually started really making some
progress in my company and so whatever
whatever disadvantage that you think you
have turned it into a strength so you
know if you are 13 and you want to go
off and teach piano and you've never
learned how to play piano yourself like
don't go do that try to think about for
people who have money right who can
spend if you want to make a lot of money
by the time you're 16 it's probably not
going to be selling you know bananas to
your 13 year old friends think about
someone who has money and think about
what kind of value you can provide them
if you if you ask yourself that every
day right you look at somebody who who
has money who has a problem and you know
that you can solve it for them if that's
always on your radar how can I do what I
love that is solving problems for people
who can pay me to do it that's the start
that's the start ask yourself that
question every day and before long you
beyond to your idea that will give you a
lot more money than just being able to
buy a car by the time we're 16 next
James thanks for all the videos
especially the ones involving comedians
appreciate the love James we try to
cover a cross-section of different
people a lot of it comes from your
request I see these kinds of things as
a double-edged sword I think one it's
it's fantastic to be able to learn from
the people who look like you who are
comedians who are entrepreneurs who are
inventors who are politicians it's it's
awesome and I would strongly encourage
everybody watching to try to pull and
learn from people who do not look like
you who are not in your field like the
amount that you can learn as an
entrepreneur from a comedian is stunning
if you are the first entrepreneur to
take advice from Kevin Hart and apply it
in the business world or in the fashion
world or in the restaurant world like
that becomes a competitive edge and so I
would strongly encourage people not just
to learn from the people who are in your
industry it's definitely a great way to
go like learn from that and learn from
the people who are outside your business
and try to think how can I apply this to
my industry and be one of the first
people to do it because that's when you
really start taking off so I'm glad
you're enjoying it next Landon when did
you when did you get your blown up
leader canvasses I want some aware where
did I get them where did I get these so
I just made them Jay Rhys was in the
Chad who gave a 20 dollar super chat
another cheers to Jr eyes Thank You Man
he helped me make the first one so this
was the first one Steve Jobs if you go
back on my channel way back you'll see
in the background just one and then when
I when I moved here I only had the one
and then included everybody else and
part of the challenge was we had to blow
them up so the quality was you know from
a picture to be able to make it into
canvas so Jay used some special tools in
software to help make it look awesome
and then I just went to Staples ordered
online like just large print custom
canvasses right like go to Google you
search it you upload your file and boom
you know two weeks later you got them
and so you know I wanted to pick five
five people who had an impact on my life
and that again when walking into this
environment would make me feel motivated
so these are not for sale it's one of
them
requested things that people ask me like
how do i buy those like you don't want
these don't buy this make your own make
the thing that makes you come alive so
we'll see maybe maybe at some point we
come up with a line of different
entrepreneur canvases that you guys can
go off into and put up on your walls it
I telling you like it makes a huge
difference having something in your
environment that gets you feeling
excited makes a huge huge huge
difference and I learned this when I was
in University and I had an opportunity
basically I want to ask this girl out in
Paris and I was too afraid and so she
walked away and I never asked her out
and I regretted that and I took a
picture of the area and then I went home
and I put it on my wall so it's 19 years
old 18 years old I put it on my wall
there was a reminder every day to not
live with regret and I never told
anybody about the story I I mean I for
these I've told a little bit about the
story before but for people who walk
into my room I never told people about
what that story was it just looks like a
beautiful French you know Riverside
picture but that was a daily reminder
like I will not live with regret the
next time this thing happens I will be
willing to deal with the failure but I
won't be willing to deal with not
knowing right if I ask a girl out
I can deal with her saying no but I
can't deal with her with me not knowing
and that's what gave me the courage to
become an entrepreneur because I had
opportunities to join big companies and
what my thought was my dream job and I
didn't and I joined this startup company
became an owner and made 300 bucks a
month
where was the risky thing to do where
was not on my vision for where I wanted
to go but I would regret not doing it I
knew that I regret not knowing and it
was that picture on the wall that helped
me remind myself of that every single
day when I woke up it was actually
hanging at this tiny little basement
apartment it was hanging above my bed so
like I woke up and boom there's that
picture and so you know I walk in here
this makes a huge impact on me every
single day designing your environment to
allow you to feel whatever your one word
most important core value is makes a
huge huge huge impact so whether it's
doing posters or having books or
pictures whatever it is like
the day design with intent it'll make a
huge difference
next Remzi 3 3 3 how to make it in the
music industry okay couple things here
one more content practice practice
practice practice practice just like I
talked about in the speaking industry
it's never been easier to stand out as a
musician there's a ton of supply in
terms of people coming through but it's
never been easier to stand out because
it's so you don't need a record company
you don't need a gatekeeper there's
nobody holding you back but yourself I
will be looking at how can I make a song
I would I would be copying what I'm
doing I'm making three videos a day I'd
be looking how do I make three songs a
day and that may sound crazy and so when
I give advice to entrepreneurs about
this or youtubers I start off light I
say make one video a day right so make
one song a day but I really want you to
make three I want you to make three
songs every single day and with the
quantity you'll get better you'll you'll
get better be able to make it faster and
the output will be a lot better and
people will take notice like if you're
making one song a month or an album
every quarter or something where every
year like it's not enough you need to
make more content to get better and to
get a chance of standing out this is a
lot of tactics you can use so then great
you're gonna go to SoundCloud and yes
you're gonna use the right tags and yes
you can reach out to youtubers and say
hey do you want it you want some free
music for your your your soundtrack I
have it on my website I should be on my
website you go to the homepage scroll to
the bottom it says music there I'm
looking for somebody to design an audio
recording that I can use for my intros
right if you guys see the ants Presto's
does the morning I wake up every morning
right that was a song design just for
the in special series help me make a top
10 intro for me make a mentor me intro
for me right it's got to be good I'm not
gonna use it if it's crap but this is
how you start to stand out right this is
how you start to get awareness and
attention all of these people making
content they need music for it as well
and so reach out and make custom tracks
and most of that may not go anywhere
like you may reach out to me and say hey
I've been here's the soundtrack for your
top 10 maybe I don't even see that email
because they get so many maybe I listen
to your track and don't respond maybe I
listen you're trying to say you know
what this isn't my
style maybe some of the listeners
actually this is garbage never sing
again right you keep going because for
every hundred that you make three of
them are gonna say this is sick this is
great let's do something together and
that's what you keep doing you keep
grinding out the content making three
songs every one song for now right every
single day get it going
put it up everywhere do your outreach if
this is important to you then you have
to put in the work for all of you guys
watching if this important to you you
have to put in the work not in just in
the creation but it in the distribution
in the marketing in the exposure right
and so how do I manage make two videos a
day that's a great question so so that's
what I would focus on right I would
think about my craft waking up every
single day if you did that like how am I
gonna win on Instagram it's gonna be
because I will make three pieces of
content every single day for five years
and most of you won't I'm gonna make
three pieces of content I am proud of
for five years and most of you want to
win in two minutes right and so if you
are a great singer you will not be
denied but you have to have the talent
and that comes from creating the
quantity and you have to get the
distribution of putting it up on social
media networks reaching out telling
people listen to your songs offering to
do three gigs at the beginning to get
exposure and build your brand next Lewis
with a super chat of our five dollars
what's our five dollars what's what's
the what's like I love all these
different currencies coming in is great
Louis how do you create your content
calendar for YouTube so this is great
ties to none other question about how do
I make two videos a day how do we make a
Content calendar it starts with what I
am interested in and then it has to be
something that you guys are interested
in this is how you have a successful
business it always has to be a mix of
what you love and what the market wants
right what you love and what your
customers are willing to consume if I
made
so the believe love series that I talked
about before I love that I love that
series it helped me but you guys didn't
like it enough so we
killed it right and if I want to keep
doing it for myself I can but you guys
weren't fans of it and there's been lots
of series I can't remember we've killed
more series than most people even come
close to trying most series die which is
okay right and then some series take off
the top ten series started as one video
a week because I thought you know 52
people a year 52 weeks in a year 52
that's okay
and it started taking off so that okay
hmm can we do we could do how about
twice a week a hundred people a year
hundred people a year there are a
hundred people here we can profile maybe
let's try it and then as we started
making more you guys started leaving
requests can you do this person this
person this person this person a lot of
people had never heard of before
you guys are educating me on amazing
people in the world which I really
tremendously appreciate and we had a
backlog of 2,000 plus requests and
that's that allowed us to go to a video
a day so five times a week every weekday
we do a top ten rules now and so new
series comes from you guys requesting
something or me just wanting to try
something you know our newest series now
is believe films so we did one last week
on Friday on work ethic which is
hopefully awesome you guys like it we
got a new one coming up this weekend and
it's been more time invested into one
video than we've done in a long time and
I'm super proud of what I made but maybe
you guys don't like it like maybe
doesn't resonate maybe I missed them all
missed them all that's that's a
combination of mark and ball miss miss
them all I missed them all on on that
and so we might have to kill that series
right now so far it's doing it's doing
decently well so we'll see where it goes
so it's always a combination of what I
love doing and what the audience wants
and that's what you need to really think
about for your content for your products
your services a combination of what you
love doing in what the market is willing
to consume and pay for next so got I'm
17 years old what do you think I should
start a business or get a job honestly
if you're asking that question then I
would say both I think if you'd do both
I think you should think about the
about whatever industry you want to be
in what what you love doing like what
you could imagine yourself doing but you
don't have the answer for yet if you had
the answer you'd be doing your own
business so I'd be thinking about what
are these kinds of business that I want
to be in and then before launching a
company in it go work at a job go work
from somebody who you want to look like
in a couple years somebody has ten
employees or less a small company but
not just a solo person and go work for
them and see do I like this - I like
this industry I thought I wanted to be a
carpenter but now looking at this carpet
in their business I don't really want to
be a carpenter or I thought I wanted to
be a youtuber but then after working
with his YouTube I realized I don't want
to be in that game right you don't know
really until you try you can't think
your way into a business you have to get
you got to get experience you got to do
it you got to be in the trenches and see
do I love this business because you have
to enjoy the work
you can't just enjoy the outcome you
can't just enjoy the money that comes
you have to enjoy the work I like making
videos I like being here chatting with
you it's amazing that you guys are
giving me super chats and it leads a
whole bunch of other things but it
doesn't matter like I love doing this I
want to do this for you it feels me up
and so you've got to find that thing
that you love doing and so I would start
with an idea then go get a job and see
do I like this business or not and if
I'm liking it then I'm thinking okay how
do I make this my own business what can
I do on the side right the reason to get
a job is to learn right so I'm learning
I'm getting contacts I'm getting
industry experience and now I'm gonna
start my business on the side do my side
hustle work evenings work weekends try
to get my business up off the ground so
both right the danger is getting the job
and then being stuck in a career path
for the rest of your life which is
that's not what you want then do both
right you have to commit the time every
single day to building your business up
as well but I think a lot of people jump
into a business too soon and they end up
losing money losing time like to know if
you wanted to be a carpenter right I
would much rather go work for a
carpenter like go work for a carpenter
because you'll understand in a week if
that's the thing that you like doing or
not we're for you to start your own
carpentry business and get it off the
ground you might be six months in 12
months in before you get any kind of
client base coming in
and you now feel now you know what this
isn't for me you just wasted six to
twelve months instead of a week going to
learn from somebody else right so as
much as you if you don't know where
you're going as much as you can shortcut
your path by learning from somebody
who's already done it it's way way way
way way easier at least in my opinion
because I don't want you wasting time
down the wrong road next Julianne in
what ways you overcome emotional
struggles examples of how you had in
your life in what ways do I overcome
emotional struggles examples from a life
so a couple things come to mind one
again I think understanding your value
system understanding your mission
understanding who you are what you want
to do helps you stay centered at least
helps me stay centered so if you know
for me that I think the the two biggest
events for me in terms of emotional
roller-coaster
was one telling my business partner that
I quit in my first company and two was
going through my divorce with my first
wife
searching for the first one I think just
me hearing me say I quit on something
that is important to me didn't feel
right and it gave me the confidence and
courage to get up the next day and just
say you know what I have to find another
way to stand where I think if I didn't
do that if I didn't go back to the
company I said I quit and I'm out then I
would have regretted it like you've been
to this day be thinking I'm what if I
just gave it an extra week what if I
just gave it an extra month like could
I've turned that thing around and so I
think understanding who you are and the
mission that you're on helps you
navigate the waters of emotional
turbulence so if you really want to do
this if you know what you stand for and
you really want to go down this path but
your parents think that you can't or
your friends think that you can or your
first customers say that you suck you
still have the fortitude to keep going
where if you're just listening to other
people's opinions and say you don't
worry mom and dad you're right you know
what that customer X you're right and
then you don't do it you're always
living your
according to somebody else's opinion of
you or expectation of you and then
you'll never be happy because somebody
else will always have a different
opinion right there's always we other
expectations people always have a plan
for your life and it's not until you
decide what your plan is for your own
life that you start to live in
congruence and live happily and then be
able to deal with the crap that comes
alongside doing that
so just self-awareness Kyle $2.00 super
chat I appreciate a Kyle how do you go
against the grain like Trump so you know
I think especially in in the era now
that we're in with social media it's
never been easier to get a message out
there it's never been easier to spread
your mission it's also never been easier
for people to see through fakeness an
inner --then to city right it's never
been easier to spot BS it's it's looking
at a lot of corporations and their
messages and their commercials and what
they're putting out on social you know
it's just BS a lot of it and you don't
buy into it and so this is exciting
because this is your chance as an
entrepreneur it's your humaneness right
your realness that's what needs to come
out and so I think it's a matter of one
understanding what that thing is that is
you right it can come down to your one
word or something else but like who is
Evan Carmichael who is Kyle right
figuring that out and then having the
courage to express it so what is your
powerful opinion and then how do you get
the courage to express it and so the
courage will come from one practicing
right like start making snapchat stories
so I'm making Instagram stories so I'm
making some content putting it out there
and the more that you have discussions
even with friends or people around you
or the more that you're creating the
content the more your opinions will form
will solidify will become more powerful
more meaningful and the more you feel it
then the more it's going to come out I
would say as well to surround myself
with people who make me feel that
feeling that I want like if the courage
is is lacking for you then be around
people and resources that make you feel
more courageous
whether that's friends in your life like
if your parents make you feel more
courageous great spend more time with
them if they make you feel less
courageous limit your exposure don't
spend as much time with them right if
watching my videos helps you feel more
courageous or watching you know even if
you disagree with Trump you can learn a
lot from chump right or all these other
people you know a lot of people hate
Kanye right but you can still learn a
lot from Kanye even if you dislike him
as a human being
same thing with C jobs and everybody
else so I think you I think to develop
confidence and courage it's not just
reading the book about confidence and
courage I don't think that's going to
help you as much as being around people
who are confident and courageous
even if even if it's not face-to-face
even it's consuming video content
watching somebody be confident in
courageous watching somebody go through
a huge trial and tribulation and they
whether they win or lose they went for
it right being around that I think will
make a huge difference for you so
planning that into your morning routine
I think will help you win another super
chat from Tracy Tracy is a huge fan I
love all the comments that she's putting
on the social media thank you for your
hard work and always applying everyone's
comments you guys you got to do it you
gotta reply to comments I'm not perfect
I miss some but I do my best and I am in
my comments every single day I'm making
videos every single day and I enjoy the
process more importantly if you're if
you're thinking I kind of respond the
comments then then you've lost like you
have to enjoy the process of giving back
recognizing people in your community and
making videos like I I don't know when
the last day that I didn't make a video
was people go on about their vlogging
streak give a video a day like I'm doing
three videos a day every day the last
time I didn't post a single video on my
channel I would have to go back maybe
you guys can help do some sleuthing for
me but it's been I don't know four or
five years at least so that's how you
win like every single day for four to
five years I did a post not that long
ago like a couple weeks ago where four
years ago
had 7000 subscribers and I just passed a
million views on my channel I was
celebrating I put on my personal
Facebook then man guys thank you so much
it just cost a million views on my
YouTube channel and I have seven
thousand subscribers four years ago now
we're 1.1 million subscribers and
hundreds of millions of views on the
YouTube channel because I made a video
every single day now two and then three
and and I got better right like
hopefully the video quality is going up
if it's going down then something's
wrong and you guys tell me feedback you
guys give me the criticism when it
doesn't do well I appreciate that
and so just consistency you guys are
geniuses you guys have great ideas it
blows my mind the amount of great ideas
and energy and for the right reasons to
that come out of almost every
conversation I have with with
entrepreneurs and you guys as part of
believe nation whether it's like super
quick like this or like face-to-face
people stop me on the street saying the
frames of the channel like you have
you've great ideas and you're doing it
for the right reasons you want to help
people and I love that but you're just
not consistent enough you just give up
too soon
you're just not doing it every single
day and if I can somehow transfer my
energy and grit and hustle and just
every single day consistency even if
just watching me upload a video means
you're gonna go off and do something in
your business that's the biggest thing
that is holding back so many
entrepreneurs they just quit too soon
and they're not consistent enough and so
I really really really hope that like
you guys watching this will take that
away and stop thinking about what's
gonna happen in the next two months but
think in a four to five year horizon
that if I make a video a day for four
years I'm gonna win big if I make a song
every day for four to five years I'm
gonna win big if I make a piece of wood
like whatever your business is if you
enjoy the process and you do it every
day for four to five years you are going
to win just don't quit too soon that's
kind of a good rant to end on but we
still have five more minutes let's get
to another question
al al al Mamoon
hey Evan if someone came to you and
asked you to start a company with him
would you say yes dude I get this every
day this is the biggest challenge that I
face is that I'm fortunate in that I'm
I'm buried in opportunity I have tons of
ideas that I want to get to just like
you guys I'm sure you have a list of of
all these plans that you want to create
and and I do too I have I have big plans
for what I think the world needs my city
needs my family needs and the biggest
thing that I need to focus on is is
focus like if I say yes to this
then I'm not saying yes to this you know
one of the things I wanted to do is
create an entrepreneur cafe I think
entrepreneurs need a great place to go
and work you know I think Starbucks is
okay and libraries are okay and not
everybody has like a lot of
entrepreneurs you we're just working
from home right and it's not always the
best environment like it's nice to get
out and go somewhere that's that's
inspiring that you're around other
entrepreneurs and so this co-working
space is that kind of stuff but I wanted
to send an entrepreneur cafe here in
Toronto and I started researching sort
of sort of researching sort of come up
with naming ideas coffee drinks all the
fun stuff that goes into starting a
business and then I connected with Lily
and invested into her business and I
told her you know about a year prior so
that I wanted to be in business with her
yeah I even know what the business is
but I just like her as a human being and
I think if we do something it'll be
special and she came back and said okay
I want to I want to do it and so that
means I don't do my coffee shop idea at
least yet you know at least until I get
lose business a certain size and TDS a
certain size I started another business
with J rise in the chat a soar incubator
helping entrepreneurs launch their
companies and so every time I say yes to
something means I'm saying no to a
thousand other things and so you know I
get asked all the time from people who
want me to invest in a business or be
the partner in their business or do
something with their company I like
doing a lot of light touches like this I
consider this a lot of light touches
I'm able to answer your question but I
can't come in and help you one-on-one in
your company right I'm doing a whole
bunch of interviews and podcast and
radio shows later on today after this
and I like I like doing it like one-off
here I want to help you want to bring
value to your show but I can't be a
regular host on your channel because
from doing that and them's I'm not doing
a whole bunch of other stuff and so my
strategy has been to light-touch
millions hundreds of millions of people
and go very deep with a tiny select few
and I don't really play to much else in
the middle so that works for me and it's
it's not right or wrong it's just what
works for me and so you got to find the
strategy that works for you Jerez is
linking up the soar link there it is if
you want to go check it out you can
learn more about the incubator its
accelerator it's a little different
model than usual and you got to be able
to face some harsh truths but it's worth
checking out printf I'm 17 what do you
think is more important study or working
on the idea of startup that you have in
mind again both both both both both both
both both as soon as you start putting
the world into an either-or world that's
when you lose you have to do both do
both how do I successfully do this
answer this we do this means they're
both important to you mix like the
combination of those two things is where
you will win trying to only do one thing
means you're losing out on this thing
and if that's what you want or that's
part of what you aren't or that's
filling a hole in your heart you have to
do both and be one of the first people
to figure out how to mix them right and
so that's that applies across the board
should I start this business or this
business well if you like both and find
a way to do both that's your answer like
be the first person to do both because
if you go all in on one you'll loose
because you always want to do that other
thing too and there's somebody else who
loves doing that other thing all in and
they're gonna crush you so be the first
to do both both both both and and and
stop thinking or it's always and and yes
yes yes yes and and and do both forever
always for five years and then you win
yes that's it okay guys thank you for
the love it is new and it's been an hour
that's always a ton of fun working with
you answering questions means a lot to
me I hope you can take some of this
energy and in content in apply it and do
something today you know even if it's
midnight where you are you're not going
to bed yet so do something right now
that you will be proud of today matters
stop wait until tomorrow stop wait until
next week today's important today is the
most important day of your life treat it
so and it will become so and do that for
five years and you win thank you guys
I love you continue to believe and
whatever your one word is which love
I'll see you next week